l'arrivée de gennaro à la mine dambre
dominicaine alors c'est une scène qui
est intéressante parce que quand on
connaît lambres dominique a on le sait
on sait qu'ils datent de l'oligocène et
du milieu c'est non c'est pas vraiment
duquel des deux il est peut-être à
cheval entre les deux mais voilà c'est
un nombre qui est très récent et qui n'a
jamais connu les dinosaures non aviens
en fait donc c'est un nombre qui est 30
millions d'années trop jeune pour avoir
préservé le moindre moustiques ayant
piqué un dinosaures non aviens donc
c'est plutôt intéressant en fait d'avoir
cette scène où on a un collabo la halle
un collaborateur de john amende donc le
gars moustache avec le chapeau qui
fouille dans une mine dambre pour john
amende pour trouver des fossiles qui lui
serviront à rien à jurassic park en fait
[Rires]
c'est plutôt intéressant en plus la
halle si on connaît un peu les mines
dambre dominicaine en fait normalement
c'est des tunnels verticaux c'est pas
des c'est pas des trucs horizontaux où
justement on peut rentrer avec son
costard cravate comme le fait janeiro
non en fait c'est des tunnels verticaux
on y va en étant attaché un armé et puis
ces décès des conditions de fouilles qui
sont évidemment très dangereuse donc
hors de question d'y aller en costard
est ce qu'il ya des en fait ce qui est
très marrant avec cette scène c'est pas
tellement le fait qu'ils se sont trompés
de mines dambre en fait qu'ils ont pas
pris une mine dambre du bun h c'est
surtout que quand on regarde de très
près la can de john hammond un peu plus
tard dans le film on constate que c'est
un morceau dambre sur sa canne qui n'est
pas un vrai
ces deux morceaux de machin qui ont été
collées ensemble alors c'est normal
c'est un accessoire mais c'est marrant
en fait on pourrait presque s'imaginer
qu'il ya un message sous jacent que tout
est faux en fait de que c'est toujours
le cirque de puces rappelez vous
donc tout est faux à jurassic park
jusqu'à la can de john hammond et jusqu
à lambres qui sert à ressusciter les
dinosaures